i know your whole history with mormonism
and your whole family is like in that i
didn't know much about mormonism but
it seems like it's kind of cultish
and everyone has to think the same way
and your family was so steeped in it
that you felt like [ __ ] my father
doesn't get me he doesn't understand me
i wish that he could see the world the
way i do this is a great question and we
should really dig into this because when
we were last on
we talked about this and it was really
hard for my mom because they're all
still mormon and i it was actually the
best thing that probably happened in our
relationship was when i was on here last
time it perpetuated a conversation with
her
that i
was never able to have and now we're in
such a great place but i'm a very open
book and i'm very honest so let me
answer that question one uh in my in
regards to my dad
no my dad is the
i was gonna say the [ __ ] best but
i know he's probably this so probably
wouldn't appreciate the f word but i
love my parents are so damn great and
for many years in my youth i was angry
about mormonism
i did feel like the wool was pulled over
my eyes and i'd anger towards my parents
as i get older i look at it and it works
so beautifully for them
it doesn't work for me
it works for
a lot of people whether it's a cult or
not
it feels almost like everything is a
cult to some degree to me i guess um
and
that word carries so much weight that i
just look at it and i i'm a true seeker
now i'm looking for truth and i feel
like there's truth and a lot of things
and there's [ __ ] in a lot of things
you're right what i was referring to is
when you're steeped in that world and
you grow up in that world
where do you find the intelligence and
emotional bandwidth
to break free let's say with the
church's teachings about gays
which you've you know famously done
you're very big supporter of lgbtq
rights and all of that how out of your
whole family do you break free of all
that nonsense i mean from a young age it
felt like a very very contradictory
thing because you're going to church and
you're learning about jesus and you're
learning about love everyone accept
everyone that really is the root of
christianity which mormonism is steeped
in so it didn't make sense ever never
made sense to me and then i got into
high school and
there was a kid at our high school who
was gay and mormon and he went in front
of the mormon temple and shot himself
in las vegas and
i think that was a real turning point
where it was like yeah this this doesn't
make sense but now it was like you know
actually this seems really messed up
is that the thing that did it for you in
order to sort of break free of all that
thinking was that
that put me on a path but the thing that
did it for me
was uh one of my dear friends tyler
glenn he's the singer of neon trees we
went on the same mormon mission to
nebraska
you don't get to pick where you go
you were on a mormon mission and they
sent you to nebraska where did you where
did your brothers go where did they get
together the philippines japan
england so at the time when i'm 19 and
you're supposed to do this i was like
well i don't believe this
this is really hard for me but i'm gonna
get to learn a cool language i'm gonna
go to africa i'm gonna go to some cool
place it's gonna be adventure for two
years and then i open my mission call
and then
you read it a line at a time you like
cover up the lines all my family's in a
room and i'm like dan reynolds you have
been called to serve and all my brothers
are like
omaha nebraska and everybody was like oh
oh it's going to be great when you go on
a mission what is it you're doing in
omaha nebraska for two years i knocked
doors all day so you knocked doors i
would my best technique was i put the
book of mormon on the top of a door
frame and knocked the door it would be
just on the top of the door frame about
to fall they would open it and i put my
hand on the door frame and just that
pressure would make it fall into my
hands and i go oh a gift from heaven
i'm elder reynolds and i'm here to teach
you a message about jesus christ that
would give you lots of doors they were
like okay i don't want to hear your
message but that's cute you can come in
you know that was cool i would have
probably right out i'd be like dude come
on you're going to use a cheesy line on
me what am i a woman you're picking up
it didn't work on everybody it was like
you know 50 do you look back at that as
like [ __ ] that was two years of my life
wasted or do you look at it like okay
everything's contributing to who i am
today yeah i wouldn't be here if it
wasn't for it um but man the first week
i wrote my mom a letter you get to call
home twice a year mother's day christmas
other than that you write a letter once
a week home no girlfriends no phones
anything like that you just knock doors
all day and if you knock by the way and
someone says no so if i knocked on your
door howard and you said no that's
[ __ ] it's a cult i don't want it
then i have to say
but can i be of service to you and you
can ask anything this is a i hope
everybody like takes this and takes
advantage of our missionaries you say
yes i want you to in nebraska for
instance castrate my horse then i went
and castrated horse brand my cows brain
cows roof my house roof clean up the
feces in my kitchen because my house is
going to be taken from me okay take a
shovel and you could do that that's what
you do wow
and people did it like you you in other
words you have to say yes
what was the worst thing you had to do
besides castrate a horse there was a
house that was uh he was gonna have his
house taken from him uh this guy and he
was just not completely there and he
said can you help me clean my house we
said yes and we came in and there was
just [ __ ] up to your ankles
almost the entire rats roaches all of it
and then you just shovel [ __ ] yeah oh my
god what a [ __ ] but
i believe that uh
i i genuinely believe that i wouldn't
there was work ethic there are certain
unknowns that i can't you know i don't
even know what they were but here i am